[Music]
the i-team learning a federal water
shortage declaration on the colorado
river is expected on monday that will
trigger some mandatory cutbacks lake
mead where we get 90 percent of our
water sits at record low levels now
valley residents are urged to conserve
water and this afternoon the i-team is
taking a look at residents who are
considered to use the most now keep in
mind the information is based on 2020
usage so homeowners may have sold their
property or maybe replaced grass with
turf since then vanessa murphy vanessa
murphy's showing us how the i-team
hasn't covered it
the average resident in southern nevada
needs to know who's using the most water
casino moguls business leaders musicians
athletes doctors lawyers and others the
i-team obtained these lists which reveal
top residential water users as the west
faces a crisis
our water situation right now is
unprecedented kyle rorink is the
executive director of the great basin
water network which promotes water
conservation he points to the first ever
shortage expected to be declared for
lake mead i feel like the folks that are
using those exorbitant
amounts of water on an annual basis
are not in touch with reality topping
the list a home which records reveal
belongs to the prince of brunei the las
vegas valley water district reports his
spanish trail property used more than 12
million gallons of water in 2020 that's
about a hundred times more than the
average home uses bronson mack with the
las vegas valley water district says 20
percent of customers use about 40
percent of water we do have a very high
end
group of customers that use a
significant amount of water second on
the list a summerlin home which records
reveal belongs to the adelson family
also in the top 10 the greenspun family
ironically one week ago in the las vegas
sun newspaper owner brian greenspun
turned over his column to the general
manager of the southern nevada water
authority the topic water conservation
the i-team has uncovered clusters of top
water users in some of the most high-end
guard gated communities homeowners on
the so-called billionaires row in
summerlin by the tpc golf course include
steve wynn david copperfield and lorenzo
and victoria fertitta all in the top 10
in the city of las vegas at mcdonald
ranch a home which records reveal
belongs to nancy walton a member of the
family which started walmart is number
five in the city of henderson celine
dion's lake las vegas home is listed as
number 12 in henderson mike tyson's
number 30. in the city of las vegas nba
player demarcus cousins is number 16.
aja walkman singer and wife to imagine
dragon's front man dan reynolds is
number 61. floyd mayweather 84.
five-fingered death punch member zoltan
bathory has two homes in las vegas and
henderson both listed in the top 100. it
exemplifies
you know this what we've seen for years
in southern nevada is that you know
people with more power and more money
tend to consume a lot more water but
we're all in this together
well we have part two of this report
coming up tonight at six o'clock vanessa
will show us what one of those top users
is doing to get his property off the
list